[Music]
this is a lei wofe it's a vaporizer for
liquid you can use it for any liquids
from juice and soda to alcohol to soups
and sauces the wok turns any liquid you
pour it into it into a flavorful cloud
you can sip using a special straw this
gives you a little flavor of the drink
without any of the calories or in the
case of alcohol any of the effects start
off by pouring whatever beverage you
want into the carafe if you're gonna be
using alcohol it's better to add in soda
or juice or another liquid because
liquids that have a high water content
tend to work the best in order for it to
work properly you need to fill it up to
the line which is about 1/2 liters after
you've poured your drink turn laid-off
on its side this activates the electric
crystals that turn your beverage into
the flavorful cloud it's the perfect way
to geek up any party